this is a production of Cornell
University
thank you very much for the invitation
it's a real honor to be here and speak
and the chance to tell you about our
work and I will jump in so I don't run
over time and give you an overview on
some of the really interesting questions
we've been able to ask in fungal
evolution and so I want to also pay
tribute to the beauty of the different
organisms that we get to work on in
fungal biology and in my ecology and
this is sort of just a couple of plates
from a recent paper book chapter that we
put out that is part of this new book
called the fungal Kingdom where there's
a lot of really great chapters about
different aspects of the globe biology
but it includes some paying homage to
some of these these beautiful beautiful
structures and I think what I want to
emphasize is that if you don't work on
fungi is that they are of course you
know many different cell types and
sudden shapes and sizes and colors that
we see and at trophic interactions and
so trying to understand the evolution of
these groups of organisms how they're
related to each other and how some of
these different forms came about is one
of the driving questions that we've the
we've been doing in my lab and across
the the collaborative community on this
work and so one of the driving questions
is what are the what are the
evolutionary relationships of the fungi
if I minimize this that's okay so what
are the evolutionary relationships among
fungi and so this has been a driving the
part of fungal systematics and first we
used morphological characteristics
sometimes Ecology's to group things then
with the ability to use molecular
systematics to it resolve the fungal
phylogenies that was driven in part by
the ability to peat use PCR to sequence
the the ribosomal locus regions and then
one of the landmark papers in 2006 as
part of the trio life work was able to
use a six gene phylogeny to resolve the
major lineages and we thought okay we've
got a good map of how these organisms
are related but in fact as we start to
look carefully at those trees we realize
there are places that we don't really
fully understand the resolution
so we need additional sampling of both
markers and lineages to get at that and
some of the places that I'm going to
emphasize where we didn't know that we
don't know the answer and we maybe still
have questions relate to some of what we
might call early branches or at least
what are what are the less appreciated
lineages in the past perhaps but things
like zygoma seed fungi and the
flagellated Kitteridge fungi were some
of the order of the branchings have been
unresolved and that even with within
groups of things that are well studied
like to the studio my seeds which
include mushrooms but also Smuts and
rust some of those relationships
unresolved even with with sort of large
sampling and gene sets so one approach
to try to solve this problem is to
sequence more and so one one question
that we'd like to understand is it was
is how they're related but why do we
care about the tree so being able to
have a tree of how they're related to
each other
allows us to look at when characters
evolved when did ecological associations
arise do they arise multiple times not
all plant pathogens come from a single
origin so timing when those those
changes occurred but also in look at
more broader context the the rise of
diversity of fungi could be correlated
with the rise in diversity of plants a
rise in diversity of insects and so
understanding better the timing is what
the phylogenetic work allows us to
present and then to correlate that with
other kinds of characteristics and in on
top of that we also can see things like
interesting morphological origins and so
for example on the top left here I'll
only briefly talk about this fungus
called endogamy which looks like a
truffle but as part of the zygoma a
fungi which are typically we look at
them as filamentous molds and so we have
examples of things that have really
complex morphology embedded within a
group of organisms that don't share that
and so understanding how many times
those kinds of complexities arise is
really interesting and requires a well
resolved phylogenetic tree and
relationships so how do we get at that
we try to sequence on two things to get
at this better right this is probably an
overused graphic but the idea that we
would like to understand how they're
related the easiest thing that we can do
especially with today's technology is
just turn the crank and generate more
sequencing and so of course through our
partnership with the joint genome
Institute where there's a lot of
sequencing capacity and the and the
interest and ability to try to generate
more sequencing more genomes and and and
sampling the the the lineages to to
capture this diversity and so our effort
that would the initial what we call
community sequencing project that we
proposed was was we called it a thousand
fungal genomes because we wanted to have
a big large number and there were there
at the time approximately five hundred
families of fungi so this is the Noah's
Ark of fungi we get to from every group
and we make sure they're covered
truthfully they're of course more than
that but more families than 500 but this
is a nice starting place and so the
initial goals are to better reconstruct
the phyla
phylogeny using many gene phylogeny is
not a six gene phylogeny but also to
look at how the genomes evolved look at
how they change and content look at
things like how Congress carbohydrate
active enzyme chain enzymes have change
which relate to how organisms get their
nutrients but also other aspects of
their biology so I'm going to give you a
survey of some of the things that we've
done I'm going to indulge myself a
little bit and talk a little bit about
some side projects I think are
interesting that we're related to some
of these investigations and then tell
you one story about about complex
multicellularity so another part of this
is of course it's important to to take
sometimes a focused approach to some of
these questions and so one group that's
not received as much attention in the
past for some of these genome sequencing
projects and and molecular genetics in
some ways has been what might be called
the early diverging fungi but does I go
my seat's and also the kids read fungi
and so as I go my seats were previously
thought to be one lineage but I'll show
you in a second that there are actually
two major lineages of that that that
constitute what are called Zygo my seats
on our funded project to look at these
was to target about a hundred and fifty
reference genomes in this lineage and
these lineages and also to generate
between 500 and a thousand like coverage
genomes that allow us to fill in the
gaps so I'm going to take a second okay
we live in 2017 even when we propose us
it was 2014 but though we could take a
really understudied group of organisms
and proposed to do 150 genomes in that
it's kind of staggering to me to think
about where we where we are in the in
our in our lifetime and are in a
technology that we have available to you
and the cost so I cannot i can't project
yet what's going to be ten years from
now how house i'll straight forward
hopefully some of these things are gonna
be and and and the scale of things that
we can do so I want to take some time
for flippant about how many genomes we
can sequence but I do recognize that
this is this is a nice a nice thing that
we can that we have access to now and in
a way to drive our sequence our
questions by sequencing so in addition
to sequencing we also want to understand
the biology these organisms and previous
work had been looked at aspects of the
characteristics of these so for example
fungi that grow in Highfill forms have a
have a concentration of vesicles at the
tip called the spits incorpor and that's
found in Icaria fungi like like
Aspergillus or Neurospora um and it's
found in some of these eigem I see fungi
which form hyphy but not all of them and
so Robbie Robertson who's an expert in
imaging has been working on using this
big collection of zygoma see punch I
didn't look at which of these have spits
and corporate and when that evolves
that's one side question that's that's
being looked at a second thing is that
these are typically when if you teach my
ecology you take my ecology we talk
about Zygo myci fungi as seem acidic is
that they don't have cept up but in fact
that is not the case for all of these so
understanding when and how septal septal
compartmentalization evolved in these
groups is important and that's the other
thing just just to show you we don't
know everything about these fungi when
you have better imaging I hadn't movie
but it's not it's not going to show here
but these little vesicles here we don't
know what they are they're probably
lipid containing but they actually move
quite fast I have a real-time video and
it is moving quite fast and and this is
a more DRLs species that makes lots of
lipids okay and so so understanding this
is you know useful in the industry but
also interesting from from a biological
standpoint and then the flossing is just
that it's a technological project and so
some of these efforts to generate
single-cell genomes because some of
these organisms we can't grow alone
so we have to grow them with a host and
so some of the projects with the jgi are
about taking infected tissue and
isolating single sport single spores or
single cells sequencing those we have
several single cell genome projects that
are going on okay so what can we do with
some of these genomes I'm gonna give you
some ten thousand foot view views of
these data and so for example um these
genomes vary in size right now and this
sort of sampling that I'm showing you
between excuse me ten you know a to two
hundred and fifty mega bases and in size
now there are fungal genomes that are
about seven hundred mega bases to about
1.5 Giga bases these are some of these
intimate pathogenic fungi they're harder
the sequence because they're so big but
we do have draft assemblies of a few of
those and so there are some things that
are bigger than that and full of
transposons but here's a snapshot of the
of the main bulk of about 400 of these
genomes that have come out and what you
can see is that his genome size gets
bigger you have more genes but you do
have species that fall off that curve
that have large genomes but not so many
genes and those represent genomes that
have a lot of trans poseable elements in
their genome so the genome was bigger
but that space has taken up with by
transposons not coding protein coding
genes so that's interesting
observational E and we can also look at
the next page we can also look at
another dynamic of that genome size and
gene gene size so for example some of
the organisms have very small genomes
Micro security are these obligate
intracellular parasites they have very
small genomes at the bottom left corner
here you know two mega base 4 mega base
genomes and they but they also have very
short genes on average so you've made
your genome smaller and the genes in
your genome have gotten smaller so
that's an example of presumably of
contraction and then you have other
organisms that have long transcripts but
not necessarily a bigger genome of the
up at the top here so there's different
patterns not everything can be ascribed
to ecology but those are interesting
observations we can make and then one
other thing that we can look at is just
the genome the
the size of the genome and the number of
introns that we see and so this is a
case where we can see of different
clades so the colors here represent
different major clades of fungi that
different clades have really different
properties and this is again indulgence
to my PhD thesis where I worked a little
bit on this and what we find is that
things like sacra mica Tina
so Saccharomyces have very few introns
that's that top left corner here right
so they have they only have like 300
introns in the whole genome and some of
these species um and then then we have
other species down here at the bottom
the mushrooms that tend to have many
many and introns per gene okay and so
the scale is kind of reversed cuz it's
about how big the exons are not how many
introns but this but the idea is that so
you can see that this kind of falls out
by some of the colors and so there's a
history in how intra gene structure
involves in fungi and we're able to
compare that across across common sets
so anyways there's differences fungi
fungal genomes are not uniform that
might be one takeaway that you can get
from this and some of that's driven by
historical patterns okay so how do we
understand how these organisms are
related to each other so one thing we
can do is try to build phylogenetic
trees and so one pipeline that we use is
using both a set of predetermined
conserved proteins um that we have about
we have 434 that we picked out that that
behaved well as being found in most
fungi and also in some of the out groups
that we were going to use and we we
identify these proteins in all of our
genomes in a rapid succession and then
build multiple alignments of each of
those we can trim and quality control
and concatenate those and build
phylogenetic trees from concatenated
datasets as well as individual gene
trees we look at congruence of all of
these and try to a generator
a consensus phylogeny of the organisms
to understand how they're related so for
those again this is maybe for those of
you who are interested in the methods
part and then we're also trying to
understand when the these organisms
diverge from each other so we also
incorporate a fossil data that's been
collected and and calibrate some of the
time points in in the in the tree okay
and when I first heard his project was
like a flint I don't leave fossils what
do you need but Tom Taylor the late Tom
Taylor and his work did
using work on paleo botany and being
able to collect and identify and
characterize structures that seem to be
fungal and he was part he was part of
our grant project grant and our project
to to collect more of these especially
for this i go myseif fungi but also to
put that in so again I've already showed
you this tree we can generate a really
big beautiful tree that is hard to read
and then we can start summarize that and
submit the other major lineages and so
some of the things that we we learned
and I'm going to come back to this point
again is that we do these are sort of
known relationships of the dike area
fungi that asked on my seats in the city
of my seats but that one of the major
findings is that what we called the new
quorum I Koda now represents these three
lineages um used to be kind of an in a
arrayed more more closely with the Dyke
area that this glow marrow Mike Mike
Mike Cota used to be more closely
related here and now we find them as one
group and that the second group we call
ZOA Pago my coda represent organisms
that are in some of pathogenic fungi as
well as Mykel parasites that in fact
that in fact other fungi so those are
really fun to study but hard hard to
dissect in the lab and then we have some
unresolved lineages in here that
represent lineages of the Katrina my
coda which we have the kids and the
blasto create in my code of both of
these groups have flagella flagellated
zoa's for fun drive but the branching
order has been a little bit ambiguous we
do think that probably blasto clade in
my coda is the earliest grant as is the
sister to the rest and that these that
the Katrina my code or sister to these
but that's in still a little bit
challenging and again there's other
unknowns that we have now I can just
throwing in here more for the
aficionados that help us try to we have
the city obelisk and an opium which are
part of the this looks like a kid but it
actually groups within these groups
right now and so trying to understand
these relationships is still part of
things and things that are ongoing okay
so how do we look at the dating of this
of this this phylogeny
by incorporating these different fossil
calibration points we're able to put
some dates on the fungal emergence and
so one of the interesting things is
there is a window of time when many of
the fungal of phyla emerged
um which which is also related to
similar timing to win we start to see
the explosion of land plant diversity so
there's but but what's interesting is a
lot of these are kind of time to the
same within the same period and that
that a lot of that the diversity that we
see kind of arose here and this in this
win this window of time as best we can
we can estimate so again these are these
are helpful in trying to put the context
as to wind and fungal diversity come
about and again if you didn't sort of
haven't seen this before but we do think
that kind of the origin of fungi
depending on how you how you define
fungi but is probably in about a about a
billion years ago so that's an old group
of organisms if you if you put them all
on that the way I say if because there's
some debate or some some worth a
discussion about how do you define the
what is a fungus and there's actually
great chapter from Tom Richards in that
book about about these definitions but
at any rate this is a helpful to look at
the context so what can we do only look
at these genomes of these organisms and
so one aspect that is interesting is we
can look at gene diversity and
innovation and duplication so what I'm
plotting here is this is as a species
tree of about seventy two fungi and I'm
putting in these colors the these these
circles where there are pulses of more
copies of gene families and so the idea
is this is when there is divert there
has been innovation in the history of
these organisms and so you can see that
there are a couple of so it's not
uniform right it's not that there's a
pulse and every node there are certain
nodes that have a lot of games and so
these seem to be related to this this
this big burst of diversity and so one
of the things again when we talk about
one wended fungi emerge at this this
label I put here at the bottom there
isn't a lot of diversification happening
at that node it actually happens a
little bit later in terms of the games
that we see in terms of the new gene
families in new diversification but
that's an interesting another way that
we can kind of put this in context so we
do think this helps us better understand
when some of the changes that might have
driven some of the fungal specific
biology
what might have occurred I mean we also
do find big examples of gains and I'm
gonna talk more about this group in a
second that relate to horizontal gene
transfer as well okay so the one group I
was just mentioning and I'm gonna go
through some of this a little bit
quicker so I can get to the end but is
that the is the Neo Callum astok of my
code of fungi which are really fun to
say ten times fast in the row but are
the anaerobic gut fungi so you can find
these if you we're on an on-campus so
you might have cows that have fistulas
you can go in there and you can sample
fluid from the rumen and inside that
anaerobic fluid you can culture
anaerobic fungi and these are Zola's
pork fungi that are really weird
they don't have mitochondria they have
hydro zomes and they are obligate the
anaerobic and so in a project that we're
working on with Mustafa al Shaheed and
know how Yusef at Oklahoma State is to
sequence transcriptomes because these
genomes are a little bit hard to
sequence the pretty repeat heavy we
secrets transcriptomes
of about twenty-five twenty to
twenty-five of these species to try to
better understand their relationships
and so and this is a tree showing the
dating of this which is interesting in
this context because the so there this
group of anaerobic gut fungi these are
all the lineages that we can find were
able to sample of these groups and that
they emerge relatively recently they
actually a merv emerge pretty close to
that's what this green box here is the
origin of her Bavarian and mammals so
the ecological niche where we isolate
them from correlates in time with the
age of the group now there's a whole lot
of time on this branch between that
where did they come from before there
were room and guts to live in I don't
know but this is what we can talk about
with the samples that we can sample
today so there's maybe new other
interesting diversity oh look out but
this is an interesting way to look at
that and then one of its re another
thing we can look at is the is the
evolution of some of this different
structures and so for example some of
these have polycentric and mono centric
forms and so we can see again that those
probably emerge multiple times within
these lineages and so again being able
to look at now gene content and genes
that are found in these groups is part
of trying to understand the
diversification there so and we can even
find genes
a kind of a pictorial just a and I just
was just to remind me to tell you that
these these fungi have lost certain
processes and gained other things and so
here's an example of a gene that's not
found in any any other fungi except for
some of the except for one weird group
called the called the city of the city
obelisk but that they have game genes
that an example of a gene that is
probably related to its it's gross an
ant it's an aerobic growth and so we can
find things that probably they had to
pick up that and the reason why I'm
showing you all these branches is that
all of these organisms all of these
agent fungi have it so isn't a
horizontal transfer of just one or a bad
genome assembly what we just picked it
up accidentally it's actually found in
all of these lineages and it's
diversified probably following the
species diversification so these might
be genes that are necessary or important
in that adaptation to being to that
ecological niche so we think this will
be cool ways to better understand the
biology as we start to map these and
there aren't that many genes that fall
into these categories of being unique to
or may be missing from the these
anaerobic ones but we do see again okay
so another thing we can do when we have
these genomes is try to ask other
questions about genome evolution and one
interesting thing that people ask a lot
in plants but hasn't been asked as much
in fungi is what happens when you get a
genome duplication now there's a well
told story about Saccharomyces
cerevisiae there was a whole genome
duplication about a hundred million
years ago and we can we can map what
happens to gene duplicates in the cut in
the time that occurs after the
duplication and this is really cool for
evolutionary biologists because there's
lots of theory about what happens when
you duplicate genes and you see what
happens after that and in plants one of
the ways that this was looked at from
transcriptomes in fact and something
from ken Wolf's lab that was first
published where these were these these
graphs where you show a plot of the
average synonomous site differences so
synonymous sites are are are neutral
basically supposed to be neutral changes
that you can count basically they're
calibrated with time so if you have a
whole genome duplication and you had a
hundred genes and you duplicate that to
200 genes and each of those has a pair
okay and at time point zero right after
the duplication the difference between
any of those pairs is zero because
they're
identical but as time passes and an
independent mutations occur in those
those those gene pairs each of them
starts to get different from each other
and that difference we can measure with
the synonymous sight difference and so
that difference looks kind of like a
peak it's not perfect right not every
gene gets the same number of changes but
that peak starts to move over time and
so you can actually guess when the
duplication occurred by looking at the
the the distribution of this peak right
and in plant genomes when we've seen
multiple duplications you see one peak
and then you see actually another peak
for multiple duplications there's like
an echo okay so that's what that's the
model that's the way you can approach
this so we can do this we have 300
genomes we can look for parallel I guess
genes and those genomes and we can ask
what's the synonymous site diversion
stuff though
okay and we can find examples like this
for a fungus like a Kittredge fungus
called alum Isis which has this nice
pattern of lots of things that are
duplicated right this is the sort of
distribution that we see um and it looks
like it's probably actually a diploid
assembly but they're the alleles are
pretty different from each other so they
didn't collapse into one so I don't know
the actual biology of why it has so many
copies but this is an example where we
think it's probably because it's a
diploid and we can look at something
like this across all of the genomes all
of the genomes and we get these patterns
right so nothing to nothing to look at
specifically there but we can pull up
something like Saccharomyces cerevisiae
where the duplication occurred a hundred
million years ago so that KS value has
gotten really big they're not that
similar to each other all right this one
has this about 0.5 for the for the
sacrum I C's again there's only a few
that are really similar everything is
kind of enough time has occurred okay
but we can look more carefully you can
actually find an organism that does seem
to have this whole genome duplication
that occurred quite recently and that's
a fungus called hor Te'o or an FBI and
this had been previously described so
I'm cherry-picking here it's had already
been known as a genome withhold you
implication and they had done an initial
kind of low-quality Illumina sembly and
we did a pack bio assembly in
collaboration with Korena snows lab in
Canada and were able to then look at the
genome duplications and identify that
most genes were in this Janice orange
category here where it were duplicated
so most of the genes in the genome had
two copies and then we can look at the
dates of those gene the the
which age of those and see that
divergence time and so what's cool about
this is this is probably the this is
really a real whole genome duplication
and it's probably the most recent one
that we can identify based on these
comparisons of all the genomes that we
have because there's so many genes in
the genome that have that are that are
basically one-to-one paralogs
and that we can we can we can wrap it on
and so this is what it looks like it's a
black yeast it's an extreme of file in
the sense that it grows in really high
salt concentrations it was isolated
originally from these salt earns when
you make sea salts and you let the water
evaporate you can find some fungi
growing and this really high salt
molarity you could also find it in
marine environments and it's kind of
cool because they call it a yeast but
actually it grows filamentous lee it's a
video might seat and so if you look kind
of at that you know you look at these
cells under a dissection scope you can
see that they're actually these colonies
that have high c coming out so they're
not they're not really yeast even though
they're even they look make these kind
of gooey black stuff here when you look
on the plate and this is again oh this
my and other indulgences is that in our
lab we've also started working on some
extremophiles and so I had a
collaborating visiting student who works
on Antarctic endo lithic fungi a whole
other interesting question of you break
open rocks from Antarctica and you
culture what's inside them and you think
nothing but in fact they're a bunch of
fungi that do grow slowly and so one
species of that is called hor taya and a
species called for taya bile and akka
which is actually isolated from Thailand
so it's not only an extreme of file
living and cold but this will this is an
ice so they came from from Antarctica
and we sequenced attune above that and
put it in the tree and it's it's the
closest thing we have to it but it does
not have the whole genome duplication so
by being able to put this in the
phylogenetic context I can tell you that
there's a species that doesn't have the
duplication and a species that does so
now we have the ability look at what a
single copy gene in one species that's
duplicated into two and another okay so
this again from an evolutionary
molecular evolutionary perspective this
is a nice toolkit to be able to explore
more about that I don't know that any of
this tells us why it's able to live in
Antarctica or live in these extreme
environments but in just to advertise
that we sequence in blue or other
species from Antarctica that would
sequence the genome sport and we're
trying to understand a little bit better
how they know is are there any things
about being an extremophile that better
um Diagnostics about one other thing
about these duplicates is that we can
look at not only just the genes that are
there that copies the genes we can look
at their expression and so the gene
expression differences on the left here
in blue are how different the expression
values are for gene for these gene pairs
and so in general they tend to be very
similar to each other because they just
duplicated and they tend to have the
same nucleus or an occupancy but there
are some variation this is the this is a
comparing something like Saccharomyces
which has had a whole gene duplication
which is a lot older and so you see more
variation and the kinds of differential
expression that you're going to see
about copies but there are examples in
hor taya where there's a gene copy
that's expressed in high-salt
environments and a copy that's expressed
in low-salt environments there's there's
transporters and there's other things
about adaptation to that environment so
there's more to it than this but this is
kind of one snapshot view looking at the
ecology of an organism that's had this
duplication all right so I'm just going
to probably not going to cover
everything today which is fine
but as the zygolife project is again
this ability to sequence lots of these
genomes trying to sequence both with low
coverage genome approaches to get low
sampling sorry use low amounts of genome
sequencing to still get at enough
information to build gene trees or
species trees and try to do that can we
do a better job in sequencing the
ribosomal locus for doing bar coding and
so that's part of the driving that I'm
not going to put the trees in here for
this but it is it is working well but we
can also try to study it and so again
this is that's improved tree of the of
the Zygo my seat fungi that are really
in these two major lineages the
mucormycosis is just annoying for those
of you who teach psychology because you
got to update your slides I just want to
advertise this isn't important this is
important and trying to understand the
biology there and that again as I was
saying the Glo Maremma coda or mica Tina
do you feel like you've been demoted if
you have a mica Tina versus in my coda
but anyways these are again important
parts of that but one other thing that
we've done is that that's a little error
mic patina are an important lineage it's
hard to sequence these these are
obligate we can't
sequence them I can't grow them that
many of them in a lab so through singles
all our NSC sync single-cell amplify
amplify pation and RNA seek were able to
generate transcriptomes would work from
neko karate slab and we were and this
was just came out this finally just got
published this week but we have
improvements on the front of the
sampling of the phylogeny of the glow
Merrimack attina using this
single-celled RNA seek approach so again
improvements the phylogeny I'll just
better build a backbone that's based on
many many genes so now this is a four or
four or five hundred gene based tree
okay so this again just approaches that
we're able to use and this isn't so
important but just that pretty pictures
of these different cell types and that
we're able to grow we had to isolate
these all from from a plant and then
sort the cells and sequence from there
and in real this is all pioneered by
NEET by Nikko karate slab in in Ottawa
okay so the last thing I'm going to do
in my 10 10 minutes you want me to stop
it okay
15 okay I won't overwhelm you but is
that is this at one last question
evolution multicellularity in fun days
this is what I've been interested in
I've shown you lots of pictures of
microscopic fungi you of course
hopefully you live in a beautiful part
of the world where there lots of
mushrooms you walk outside you see a
mushroom or if you're unlucky and you
you you leave and where I am and leave
the hose on and suddenly there's just
this weird circular growing out of the
ground and your water you know in your
flowerbed so the so some fungi you like
some fun Joe you don't but the point is
that you know that there's really
different morphologies and really
different complexity that we might see
and so what we'd like to understand is
how does some of that come about and can
we can we map map win and win and time
and and what kind of changes might be
important to that and so we did this in
part because we observe these examples
multiple examples in the fungal tree of
organisms that make multicellular
structures and so here I'm showing you
sort of a sampling of the fungal
phylogeny and here I'm showing you this
thing called I'm doggin II which falls
within hours I go might see fungi
alright so most is itemizing fungi are
my croissant s we have this thing that
makes it makes a truffle it looks
something like a tuber truffle here and
then we of course have mushrooms and we
have some other other examples of
structures and one of those is an
organism called neo Lecter it's in blue
here so Neil ekta is
all within a group that you might
recognize at least one of these names
schizosaccharomyces pombe right a 4,500
gene yeast or that single cell that has
vision yeast and then we have this
organism called the Electra that makes
these these fruiting bodies look a lot
like earth tones but they're not and so
this has been an enigma as to what this
thing is first of all is it really an
ask amazing fungus is really a scum I
see fungus it falls within what we call
it to fry on my gatinha Pneumocystis is
like again like a single-cell obligate
parasite of lungs we have things in here
that this ayah saya telah is a is a
yeast so why are we seeing this sort of
thing that makes his big relatively big
structures we're how did that come about
so again if you have a hammer everything
is a nail so we sequence the genome of
it of course no this is court we can't
culture it so we had to sequence for
fruiting bodies which which worked out
okay did not make the it made a
reasonably good assembly but not not as
good as we you know you get with some of
the other projects but um but it allows
us to try to use use this system to try
to compare the Elector with these with
these multicellular fruiting bodies to
other organisms related to don't make
that as well as things that we have good
model systems for like neurons but
Krasner Aspergillus [ __ ] lens or or or
copra knob system mushrooms and so we
can take those four carcass and sequence
them and so when we look at some really
again like top level statistics our
genomes of organisms that are
multicellular more complex in the sense
that they're bigger right you would
might think that if you have a more
complicated fruiting body structure
maybe you have more genes and the answer
is no so here we go neil Ekta falls
within all of these are basically what
we might call single-celled
yeast most least forming for the most
part and here are some of our
filamentous his eyes oh my Catina fungi
here are mushrooms and you can see that
it does not have more genes than it did
its relatives or the things that it
share that well so it's not a gene count
perspective we can look and see if
there's any example of lots of gene
games because have a lot of novel genes
that nobody else has any left is in blue
here and basically we only
find the sort of number you know so
something on the order of this sort of
800 gained relative to some of its other
relatives are on this branch only about
25 genes really represents her the
novelty in this lineage so it's not
gaining a whole bunch of stuff and
losing a bunch of other stuff it's not
like it has some mass of a new set of
settings okay so that's curious that
didn't that was maybe one believable
hypothesis or still possible how long is
this that was not that was not supported
so then we wanted to look more broadly
what are the genes that we can find
other organisms that we call complex
multicellular and some of these these
organisms may accept a high fee and they
have channels to separate cells which
are really different we wanted to
understand when did this gating
mechanism evolve and I explained that in
a second and we also have um mechanisms
for how I feels together and remodel
which is really a major principle and
how you form mushrooms right there's
there's this whole nodding and fusing of
hyphy to make well and ask them I seats
to make make the sexual structures so so
are what are those genes look like in
these species and so we and this is with
Gregg Jed's lab in in Singapore who's a
cell biologist works a lot on on some of
these aspects of cell biology and in in
neuro specially and so when we started
with as we said we took organisms like
the Ross Perot and others and we asked
what are the genes that are shared among
them among organisms that we would call
complex multicellular so there's lots of
genes in the genome I'm going to walk
through a couple of these plots this one
is a set of genes that we know are
important in in plugging holes in the
septum okay and I'm pretty sure I put
the figure of what this looks like in a
second but these are a bunch of proteins
that we know are important in separating
cells and we think that separating two
cell types is probably important part of
that of being multicellular and so only
those genes are only found in these ask
on my seats are not found anything else
and then and then there are other genes
that are involved in what's called this
up support count which is another kind
of plugging technology technology or
component that fungi use again to gate
their their cells in the way that we
think about this is your
marine and you've got different
compartments and you get a you know
you're in though you're in a lab and and
someone brings a razor blade and cuts
part of your hyphy and you start to
bleed out okay if you're in the summary
and you'd like to close off those doors
and stop and stop this this cytoplasmic
leakage and so there are these pores
that can be occluded by a protein that
prevent that leakage and the proteins
that are involved in blocking those
pores in ascomycete impose eyes on my
Catina ask on my seats are these
proteins like hacks and lesion and
whiskers okay
and there's a different set of proteins
that are involved in that pour in
basidiomycetes here they're in two
independent origins of that that
technology or that or that innovation
and then these proteins here involved in
- fusions so a lot of these do not seem
to be found in the Elector so basically
that end on this this is not necessarily
showing us a component that's related to
multicellularity from our hypothesis
sort of starting out hypothesis and so
let me just oh yeah let me just visibly
show you again in in his eyes oh man
Katina you have this sort of Iraq this
lifeboat raft
I must be scared of drowning I got all
these examples here but yeah this raft
and as there's flow through there though
they get they get liberated and they
plug the hole okay in emphasizing my
Katina and there's a set the port cap
that's involved in that known we wanted
to know what does it look like in the
Elector this is what it looks like under
the e/m of that pore in the Elector so
it actually makes this protein aggregate
which is involved in plugging and i'm
not showing the picture of this
emphasize omega tina but it's similar
but different in the sense that there's
some sort of protein aggregate that's
fitting in that hole but it's not the
proteins that we know about it's
something else novel that's gone in
there and we don't know what it is yeah
we've tried a couple of different things
we don't actually have the protein yet
but visibly you can see that it's doing
that and so again just reiterating what
I just said but this is what's known and
in emphasize on my Katina there's this
hex protein that gets decorated with
these sticky things but stick together
and they're involved in plugging in that
hole and all those proteins are
necessary for that and they're not found
in they're only found in those besides
on my Catina function okay so nah that's
cool because
we further confirmed that this is a
really unique innovation at the precise
oh my Katina evolved to deal with how
they plug their septum so that is kind
of cool
it's not something that's older than the
palazzo mecca team but we can look at
other proteins so that I'm sort of
taking you down this this big picture
and there are other proteins that do
seem to be shared among many of these
but not necessarily specific to the
complex multicellularity and there are
some proteins that are involved in
really old the stripe at complex is a
really old complex it's really it's
actually found in lots of eukaryotes
that it's involved in development and so
that's they were not surprised that it's
basically found to be conserved a bunch
of these but basically our candidate
gene approach didn't necessarily pick
out totally obvious things that we were
hoping that would be able to tell us
what's going on from there but we did
use a different approach where we say
can we find genes that really follow the
pattern and it really really tend to be
in the complex multicellular fungi and
missing in things like sacrum I Caesar
Canada which are single-celled and we do
look at things involved in light regular
light response um
reactive oxygen species again also seems
to be quite not completely specific to
but but quite enriched and missing in
the sacrum ICC's lineages that relate to
reactive oxygen species and some of the
genes in terms of some of the chitin
synthesis involved in remodeling are
only found in these species that have
the complex multicellular it's not a
perfect match but it is it is useful to
look at that and so here's an example of
a protein that's a septal pore
associated protein that is for example
female sterile so it's probably a
protein involved in making a sexual
structure in this is an Arras bruh we
were able to do the experiments and we
can show that that's an important
protein that has this pattern of being
sort of only in these two fungi and not
in the others okay so we're trying to
get at more than just making gene lists
or actually trying to test these we have
to do it in Arras probe because that's a
system where we can knock out the genes
and so this is another this is a sort of
a further narrow down to novel genes
that seem to show this pattern so we
again you have to squint a little bit we
obviously use the sort of darker color
to represent um kind of degree of
conservation and so some of these
proteins maybe not necessarily all lost
in the
single cell phones although some of them
are but that but that we start to test
these are these are genes that have not
been necessary we don't know the
function of them and so they so what
Greg's but but they seem to show a
pattern that's consistent with this
complex multicellularity and so what
Greg's lab that is tagged these and look
at where they localize to and for
example you know some of these proteins
are the the details aren't so important
but that that we can look at where they
localize to and see that many of them
are in restricted membrane domains and
some of these are novel localization or
a novelty associated protein with
mitochondria so just the take home is
this is more like a framework for it is
to try to use this approach to
prioritize genes that might be important
in that process and so one final kind of
example to walk through from from the
work was that there is this um this
protein that's involved in in in this
dying binding and this this p150 glued
protein is involved in this microtubule
binding and so what's what's interesting
is this a protein what I want you to get
away from this is it's not about whether
or not the gene is present or absent
what's interesting about this and this
is what this plot is showing is that
there are parts of the protein which are
shared among the fungi that are have
complex multicellularity and they're
part of the protein that are missing and
the fungi that are single-celled so they
still have the same gene so if you just
go by orthology you can find it but that
on par most of the of the species that
don't make these complex structures have
lost parts of this protein that's
basically take home of this figure and
this figure and so the dotted lines are
the places where it's missing and those
and those are involved in some the
interactions and so it might be that
again when you think about this we have
a high fee and so some of the ideas you
have to transport things along a high
fee and so that's part of the need for
some of these binding and these these
proteins the the function that these
proteins play and so i think that's a
harder thing to write really good
software to be able to find right this
is this is an effort of really studying
the protein and knowing what it did and
knowing what parts of it were important
in order to find a pattern like this
so i mean it means are what makes our
job harder we can't just sequence a
genome and say the genes that are in the
complex ones and not in the
single-celled ones or the answer all
right so these are but these are
examples of things where i think is
dig into we could we can find a better
interpretation of the important parts
okay so and this another way to look at
that picture of that same asserting
debts that are missing in some of these
single-celled ones but that were the the
Neo Lecter protein and his sister
species really still have it but then it
starts to get lost again and shrink in
some of these single-celled ones okay so
you may not be convinced that this is
exactly what's happening but I think
these are the these are these are the
trends that we're trying to dig into
deeper instead of just looking at
presence/absence
as a way to make a character
characterization okay so again we can
look for gene loss across a big set of
species or gene gain and so for example
I didn't show you example I didn't show
you the data but we know that fidella
were lost and species that don't have
flagella and there were early lineages
that do have flagella that's a very easy
signal to find we can find those
proteins missing and all the species
that don't make fidella
but we can look for other
characteristics that relate to things
like multicellularity and here we've got
this more nuanced way of looking at it
but we do think that we have some tools
for being able to to jump into that okay
so in conclusion this is the wild west
of some of our work but some of our the
Zygo life project team is a big
collaboration of a lot of different labs
that have been contributing the
contribute to this and students in my
lab that have been been working on
different parts of this and post postdoc
usmani who did all the NIA left to work
in my group and there's the color
version of that with that I will take
and also take your kids sampling in the
desert it's always fun to do he did he
wasn't gonna smile for the camera but it
was good so with that I will stop take
any questions at any time and thank you
for your attention thank you so much for
your talk on the best organisms on the
planet I think it was a great overview
of phylogeny function and evolution and
thank you so much in commemoration and
in gratitude we have a little plaque
thank you for the lecture series
any questions yeah so in your analysis
of the time in 4G no duplications how
can you separate that from possible
hybridization events yeah that's a Greek
yeah that's a great question I guess we
would have to do a secondary set of
analyses to try to look at the well so I
think we should be sequencing more than
one individual for any given species and
that would allow us to at least add some
population variation in that to see if
the same region is oh you're thinking
like a little bit older hybridization so
sure I mean the mechanism by which you
duplicated maybe doesn't have to be an
endo duplication it could be a
hybridization that driven eyes I think
it's more are there more are there twice
as many genes is the first signature and
then you know well it depends a lot
you're gonna maintain those duplicates
so we do see in some species what looks
to be diploid that then lose hetero
zygosity and other kind of patterns that
really suggest that you kind of it's
really a diploid that does a hybrid that
hybridization as opposed to really like
maintaining a duplicate set of
chromosomes so I think that's probably
part of what we might have to tease out
as to how different the alleles are in
those duplicates to really get at it but
you're right there's a gradient yeah
there's a feature finally understand how
change became dedicated yeah that's a
great question I mean I think I think
the answer is hopefully yes we'll be
able to get at the either the metabolism
that you know requirements that have
made them obligate or that that support
on the obligate nature or the best way
to be able to have it is you have a
species that isn't obligate and to be
able to compare what's different at
least at that starting point so I guess
that's where we would start from but I
don't know that we have I haven't I
haven't focused on the on that lineage
yet there are a lot there the rust
genomes tend to be pretty big
which is interesting right there dere
obligate but they're not necessarily
like reduced and so I think trying to
understand some of that is still under
ongoing as people get more more sampling
of it I think so I think so our
extremophiles just in one part of the
tree basically or so there's a lot of
the videomic seeds that represent
represent that there are other examples
of extremophiles depending I mean
thermophilic extremophiles live in a
coupler are found in different parts of
the tree as well so cold ones so we've
we've done a microbiome I TS kind of
study and we do have what's interesting
is you can allow lichens out of that
because that's what typically is the
biomass inside those inside those but
when you go to do culturing you can get
obviously see a bit more the species
most of the ones that so we we do have
one basidiomycetes orula that seems to
be associated with with the with the
rocks but then it's predominantly do a
video my seeds that were that have been
put in the culture collections that were
able to use or we've been able to kind
of work on and there are I think there
are some other pies on my cattiness
other filamentous asked on my seats so
that the K that K three aliens would be
the other group where you see those as
well which is another there are two
groups of kind of black yeasts that and
that's kind of the other the other group
well I think so that's a great question
I think how many times multicellularity
evolved and fungi is you know somewhat
debate as to whether or not what you
define is complex multicellular so I
mean just forming a fruiting any kind of
complex fruiting body probably might be
multi-cellular so we have to so that's a
that's a debate but let's talk about
this very specific thing that plugging
you need septa to be able to have the
plugin so we don't think that the
ancestor of the fungi had it we think
that probably at least from our
reconstruction you know that the we do
see septa in some of the work all the
kicks Ella mica Tina but within this I
go my seats we do see one other example
of septa Bob we haven't we don't know
anything about the pore structure there
so I don't I don't anyways um but we but
because of this look at work at nee
electa we can at least say there's three
origins of that kind of plugging in the
examples that we've looked at there
which is more than before where we would
have just said to and previously we'd
say that the dike area fungi so the
ancestor they ask of my seats in the
city of my seats must not have had that
because we independently evolved it to
different ways so that might mean that
the ancestor of Icaria didn't really
have septa true septal need for true
septal pores until later because of that
that I mean that's the parsimonious
interpretation of that unless there's
some gain loss thing that we you know
it's really rapid yeah I think so I
think that yeah so I think that's a
final my Catina probably represent that
in that you see simplification and we
think sacra Micah T we look at the tree
sacrament Catina represents a
simplification to so probably the
ancestor of sacrum ice sheets a car
Micah teen and sacrum Isis had more it
was more complex and then you've seen
simplification or law that the genomes
are smaller and and they they have fewer
so well encoding genes a lot of things
that might be involved in that process
they don't have these Highfill fusion
genes that are shared so I think that
yeah we do think that it's actually
simplification or however you wanted to
you know that sort of has a loaded term
but like losses are driving some of that
but yeah this is one other point that
was that yeah there's a wealth of data
genetic data with yeah
yes how well does that data form well I
mean in one part we've lit we we are
still probably working on integration of
those data in the right way so there's
been sort of siloed you know there's a
really good sacrum ICC's data set
database and ability to look at gene
function in those and we can map those
on to a neurology and ask their is there
good evidence they have the same
function or they're part of the same
process
although sometimes that's a circular and
inference because the annotation inner
officer might be driven from the sacrum
ICC's homolog but um in terms of how it
maps on the file I don't know that we've
really looked at in terms of
phylogenetically I think we just tried
to ask are there consistency between
them probably the best place where it's
been done is like there's a systematic
knockout set in palm B and then sacrum I
sees right and so in that's a case where
you'd want to ask for each fourth log is
the is the phenotype pretty similar or
not in an Arras borough we have a
systemic knockout collection but they've
not been all phenotyped and so probably
about 1,500 to 2,000 have really been
phenotyped
out of that 10,000 knockout collection
so I think that's what's limiting it
right now is really to systematically
have that so people are doing like
growth rate and sexual reproduction and
a few other things are being scored but
I wouldn't say it's actually the
resources are there but I'm not sure all
of its been so the short answer is no I
have not looked at that there are a
couple labs that have been focused on
mitochondrial evolution more focused on
some of the early the kids and the Zygo
might see fungi then and others so it's
definitely an open question I guess the
short answer is it needs better work I
think there's not enough people we've
really delved into it um sometimes with
the genome assemblies it takes a little
extra effort to pool the mitochondrial
reads and called that assembly it's not
actually too hard but it hasn't probably
been done in a system
as it should be so I think it's kind of
an open space that hasn't gotten as much
attention right it's a good question I
mean I don't know if inheritance of
mitochondria is an interesting question
and sort of who which parent donates in
and in the interactions between the
nuclear genome and the mitochondria Ms
def there definitely are interesting
experiments mostly in like multinucleate
the city of my seeds in sort of tracking
things too so there are interesting
research questions about those
interactions but I don't know that like
a systematic here's all the mitochondria
and their content and what's been gained
and lost they're sort of like individual
examples of like intron gain and loss
and some of those and but but yeah I
think it's I think it's an open space
that someone needs more thank you very
much this has been a production of
Cornell University on the web at Cornell
edu